les petits déjeuners gratuits à l'école
ont été déployés en 2019
ils partent d'un constat qui ne peut que
nous interpeller
13% des élèves en éducation prioritaire
arrivent à l'école le ventre vide et
l'on sait que un enfant qui prend un
repas un petit déjeuner équilibré et
bien à toutes ses chances de mieux
travailler à l'école et que cela
renforce ses apprentissages
nous voulons donc lutter contre les
inégalités sociales les inégalités
alimentaire et renforcer l'égalité des
chances d'une part et d'autre part
mobiliser l'ensemble des acteurs autour
de nos élèves les parents les
professeurs bien sûr mais aussi les
collectivités pour travailler ensemble
en alliance éducatif afin de renforcer
toutes leurs chances de réussir avec
jean michel blanquer
olivier ferrand et adrien taquet nous
avons travaillé à un redéploiement avec
deux objectifs semblent distribuer plus
est distribuée mieux plus c'est d'abord
distribué toujours en éducation
prioritaire mais également au delà dans
nos écoles socialement fragiles s'est
distribué également aux élèves de la
maternelle à l'élémentaire c'est à dire
de la petite section de maternelle et en
élémentaire encore une fois dans cette
cible c'est également améliorer la
distribution des petits déjeuners en
allant jusqu'à un petit déjeuner par
jour si le besoin s'en fait sentir
je disais aussi s'est distribué mieux
c'est à dire travailler avec les élus en
souplesse dans le respect évidemment les
règles sanitaires et en tenant compte
des particularités et des ressources
disponibles sur les territoires